this is the all-new sixth generation
chevy camaro this car is far superior to
any car in the sports car arena but to
the camaro faithful only one other car
really matters they want to beat the
Mustang yeah I don't have any doubt
about that yes I think we will and
that's our goal absolutely no doubt
that's the aim though GM has beaten for
the past five years in a row the Mustang
has gotten a big head start since
launching its sixth generation more than
a year ago but the top-of-the-line
camaro SS now makes a whopping 455
horsepower 20 more ponies in the mustang
GT and dangerously close to the corvette
stingray we do have new camaro after we
introduce a corvette we're going to do
the best camaro that we possibly can do
we do the next corvette we're gonna do
the best corvette we can possibly do GM
now makes at least eight cars in that
segment which is why it's winning in the
higher margin performance cars market
with twenty-eight percent share our
portfolio of technology is developed
around the track and these cars racing
proves it so it's very important part of
our DNA whatever the reasons gearheads
like me rejoice oh my god that
definitely leaves you wanting more
you